it's so nice seeing you again as they
say presenting is lovelier the second
time around now here are the nominees
for Best Picture
you
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to the shape of water
the shape of water has 13 Academy Award
nominations this year winning four
Oscars tonight for production design
music Original Score directing
Best Picture
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much
growing ball growing up in Mexico as a
kid I'd I was a a big admirer of foreign
film from film idea et or William Wyler
or Douglas urge or Frank Capra and a few
weeks ago Steven Spielberg said if you
are fun if you find yourself there
you'll find yourself in the podium
remember that you are part of our legacy
that you're part of a world of
filmmakers and be proud of it I'm very
very proud I want to dedicate this to
every young filmmaker the youth that is
showing us how things are done really
they are in every country in the world
and I was I was a kid and I murdered
with movies growing up in Mexico I
thought if this could never happen it
happens and I want to tell you everyone
that is dreaming of a parable of using
John our fantasy to tell the stories
about the things that are real in the
world today you can do it this is a door
kick it open and coming thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well that's how it's supposed
to go I guess right
sorry guys we're out of Oscars what did
you want to say I'll tell them I just
wanted to say that this Guillermo is his
heart and it's everything we thank him
for letting me that's right Guillermo
del Toro everybody is your heart and
congratulations to all of our nominees
our winners
[Applause]